- President Trump,
and I was there,
I was literally negotiating
between the White
House and Congress.
The president had me here
and then I would go
across the street
and speak to Speaker Pelosi.
Speaker Pelosi would tell me
to go back to the White House.
So I was negotiating
between the White House
and Congress on this.
There was a great deal.
President Trump
even surprised me
with the number of Dreamers.
He increased it times two.
He went from 800,000 to
1.6 million dreamers.
"Pastor Sam, we're
gonna give Dreamers
a pathway to citizenship
as long as I get my wall
and protect the border and
stop all illegal immigration."
And I went back to the speaker,
we negotiated something.
And then Chuck
Schumer came along
and said, "We're not gonna
give President Trump a win."
Do your due diligence on this,
it's been extensively covered.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is the president
of the National Christian
Leadership Conference,
as well as the
author of "Be Light."
Reverend Samuel Rodriguez,
welcome to "The Rubin Report."
- Thank you for having me.
- I'm glad to have you
because there's obviously a
lot going on in your world.
Not only is it just past
Easter and the Passover season,
but obviously there's
a ton going on
on the immigration front.
And many of the things that
I've been seeing you talk about,
mostly on Fox lately,
are a lot of the things
that I talk about on this show.
And you made some
sense on cable news,
that's a pretty rare
thing these days,
so I thought I
could have you on.
For the people that
don't know you,
can you give me a little bit
about your backstory first
and then we'll move
into the current days?
- Yeah, I'm a kid from
Bethlehem, Pennsylvania,
hence Bethlehem, I have
a messianic complex.
My dad was a Mack truck worker.
My mom was a homemaker.
I graduated from
Lehigh University.
I was raised in an
evangelical home.
My parents are not preachers.
I'm a faith and science guy.
Ronald Reagan inspired the
living daylights out of me
and just prompted
this commitment
to changing America
and the world
with a value system that's
Judeo-Christian based,
but this radical
idea of God over man
and man over government.
And so that's what we do.
My commitment is to reconcile
Billy Graham's message
of Dr. King's March.
I call it the Lamb's
Agenda, it's doable.
- So you said a faith
and science guy.
I know my more skeptical
audience members,
their antennas just went off.
What does a faith
and science guy mean?
- Yeah, I'm an
evangelical trekkie.
So I'm a faith and science guy.
I believe that science
is the wonderful
horizontal expression of
the reality of a living God.
I follow everything
from quantum physics.
My encounter with God
at the highest level
took place in my
undergraduate studies
at Penn State University in
a quantum physics course.
So I did not come
through the normal,
you know watching a television
Christian broadcast.
That did not happen.
- Can you explain
that a little further?
That's pretty interesting.
- Yeah, math and
science, it blew me away.
The Newtonian laws, Leipzig,
the ever-increasing
reality of a universe
that continues to expand,
the beauty of the Big Bang,
the intricacies of the minerals
that are out there in
the universe, likewise
on this planet,
likewise in your bloodstream,
in my bloodstream,
the mathematical probability
of that happening by chance,
it requires you
to have more faith
not to believe in a
designer, and I'm sorry,
I don't have that crazy
cuckoo for cocoa puff faith.
It does require you
to have more faith
to believe this
happened by chance.
And just the math and
the science all adds up.
I'm a student of a guy
named Francis Collins
who oversees the National
Health Institute right now.
And he has been for a
number of presidents,
for Obama and Trump.
So again, he discovered
to a great degree,
unpack, unpack better
yet, the human genome,
and he is a believer.
So again, I don't
create a dichotomy
between faith and science.
I think it's beautiful.
It's one metanarrative stream
that speaks to a wonderful
architect, a designer, a God.
- Do you think that one
of our biggest problems
discussing this is that
too many people do,
"Oh, it's just either/or,
you're either a believer in God
or you're a believer in science.
These things can't touch."
- Right, that is
a false dichotomy.
Because I am a believer in
God, I'm a believer in science.
Absolutely.
And because I'm a
believer in science,
I'm a believer in God.
It's one continual stream.
I think we suffer from
cognitive dissonance.
We're lacking the sort of
cerebral bandwidth and Wi-Fi
to really look at
the big picture.
And if we do adhere
to, succumb to,
or acquiesce to the
idea of a designer,
then everything else becomes
a little bit more palpable.
And if that designer has
a plan for the universe,
does he have a design and a
plan for individual lives?
And then it becomes
more personal.
And that's where I come in
as a pastor and a preacher
and dissect that and bring
it about every single Sunday.
- So speaking of your
job as a preacher,
in this last year where we've
had lockdowns and pandemic
and people outta work
and all of that stuff,
have you noticed people looking
for something different
spiritually or from the church?
- You know what,
Dave, you would assume
that a global pandemic would
catapult the measurement
or the metric of
agnosticism, right?
Just from a logical continuum.
If there's a God,
how could he permit?
It is the quintessential
query, right?
If there's a God, why does
he permit evil to happen,
that sort of thing.
So a global pandemic, over
500,000 deaths in America,
there can't be.
Well, guess what?
Every single survey,
including one I just
read four days ago,
the level of spiritual hunger
has increased exponentially.
Now, I'm not saying
explore organized religion.
I'm saying the level
of spiritual hunger
has increased exponentially.
So, people are hungry for
a relationship with God,
for greater spirituality,
spiritual awakening, awareness.
So, that's where we come in.
And that's why I fought back
when Governor Newsom
in California,
in our collective state,
you are a part of that-
- You are in California,
you are in California, yeah.
I didn't wanna out you,
you outed yourself.
- I outed myself.
When when he deemed casinos
and liquor stores essential,
but churches and synagogues
not, are you kidding me?
Guess who gets the
call for health issues?
We do.
When young men and
women right now,
greater numbers in California
as it pertains to God,
it's unfortunate, the
suicide rate, drug abuse,
alcoholism, depression, we've
never seen these numbers.
Guess who they call?
They don't call the guy
in the liquor store.
So Jack Daniels should
not trump Moses and Jesus.
It's just illogical, but
that's what Governor Newsom did
while he was having dinner
at "The French Laundry,"
and that's another
story perhaps.
- My audience knows
that story well,
so fear not, we don't have
to dive too much into that.
But you mentioned sort
of the role of God,
of government, of man,
all of those things.
You've been able to
piece something together
that's pretty holistic
that sort of forms your
political views as well,
it sounds like.
- God over man, man
over government,
that's the pecking order.
That's American exceptionalism,
that right there.
God over man, man
over government.
And when government grows,
it's gonna sound a
little bit naive,
or, you know, here it
is, government grows,
it pushes man and
God outta the way.
This uber dependency
on government
and this unbelievable
obsession with Uncle Sam,
it's not part of the ethos
of our founding fathers.
It isn't, it's
anti-American, it really is.
This obsession with government,
instead of our God-ordained
giftings and abilities,
Uncle Sam is an uncle.
He'll never be our
Heavenly father.
He's just an uncle.
So, we respect the uncle,
unless the uncle gets
drunk in that family party.
We respect the uncle,
but we worship God.
And right now, and even
the recent proposals
from the Biden administration,
not just the 1.9 trillion, but
now the infrastructure bill,
all of this, this unbridled
growth of government,
ladies and gentlemen,
government is becoming our God.
Well, I'm pretty sure-
- And we are what we tolerate.
So we're tolerating.
- Yeah, and I'm pretty sure
the uncle is drunk
at the moment.
He's drunk and he's spending
a lot of other people's money.
Do you view that
obsession with government
as just the next
step down the road
because of the God-shaped hole?
That if basically you
are not a believer,
you gotta believe in something,
and then government just
kind of fills it in?
- Do we have measurable elements
that we can dissect historically
so it's not hype and it's
not rhetorical exuberance?
Can we measure it?
Let's measure it.
Right after World War
II, 76% of all Americans
attended a church
or synagogue, 76%.
That number according to last
week's survey from Gallup
is now 48% for the first time.
What does this mean?
Let's not forget what
we were fighting back
in the '40s and '50s, communism,
this idea of unbridled
government being God,
stemming out of the
USSR, through China,
all around the world.
Here it is, it's 2021.
Government is growing.
God, God and meaning
the belief in God,
is decreasing in America.
It's directly parallel.
It's directly proportional.
The more we get away from God,
the more government plays
a role in our lives.
I'm telling you, it's
replacement theology.
It's not like we're
doing away with God
and then there's
this great vacuum.
There is spiritual hunger
and there's hunger,
this is gonna seem a
little bit difficult for me
as a viral view, this
issue of dependency.
So who do we depend
on, God or government?
And we are replacing
God and his abilities,
giftings, his wisdom,
his pre-ordained institutions
of family and so forth,
we're replacing that
with government.
It's big government.
Big government is
anti-Christian,
it's anti-Jewish,
it's anti-Judeo-Christian value
system, it's anti-American.
And right now we are
drinking the Kool-Aid
all under the guise of
a pandemic, it's scary.
- So how do you blend that
with what I know you believe,
which is a separation
between church and state?
What should the role of
religion in state be then?
Is it just up to
the individuals?
Should the state be
fostering it somehow?
- And I know you've
done this before,
and just let me for
the audience's sake,
that separation of
church and state,
that Jeffersonian letter
to that amazing church,
we have totally taken this,
on the ideological left,
they have taken
that out of context.
And it's church should
not have a place
in the public sphere.
Quite the contrary.
Please do your due
diligence on this.
Jefferson is writing,
saying government should
never have the right,
we have to separate government
from thinking it
even has the notion
or the right for a moment
to quelch, silence, limit,
to somehow hinder, obstruct,
the free expression
of worship and faith.
So, Jefferson is
saying government
better not touch
faith and religion,
not the other way around,
not that religion and faith
shouldn't touch
the public sphere.
We have a place in the public
sphere, people of faith,
even that beautiful
faithful expression,
George Washington referenced it
at the latter portion
of his presidency
about this commitment to faith
is the backbone of this
new American experience.
Abraham Lincoln reiterated
that, Dwight David Eisenhower,
again Ronald Reagan,
of course, elevated it
to the stratosphere, yes.
So I do believe that we...
And right now that's
not happening.
Right now, government
is telling me
that I have to
change my theology
in order to accommodate
cultural shifts
that are general specific.
I mean, are you kidding me?
There are laws as we speak,
including the Equality Act,
which is not equal.
Other attempts to diminish
my ability to speak
what I believe is
truth, eternal truth,
truth that stems
from a natural law,
from a moral compass
that's way beyond
your generation
and my generation,
that is the backbone
of civilization,
and somehow I'm supposed
to sacrifice truth
on the ultra
political or cultural
or generational expediency.
So yes, there is a separation,
but to protect the free
expression of faith.
- How much of your time as
a pastor is devoted to that?
I mean, basically,
inoculating your congregation
from the whims of the day?
Because I hear from all
sorts of faith leaders
that social justice is
creeping into their synagogues,
creeping into their
churches, et cetera.
- And again, even just the
notion of social justice,
I believe in biblical justice,
biblical justice,
which is Micah 6:8,
do justice, love
mercy,, walk humbly.
It's Psalm 89:14, it's Luke 4.
So I believe in
biblical justice,
and biblical justice is an
extension of righteousness.
So, when all these things
happened last year,
I looked at my church.
Here's an interesting thing.
My church is 40% white, which
is code word for Caucasian,
40% black, which is
African-American,
and 20% Latino and Asian.
I am blessed to oversee
a very beautifully
multi-ethnically
diverse congregation.
When everything
happened last year,
I approached the
podium and I said,
"Ladies and gentlemen, we
will biblically speaking
address any and all
vestiges of bigotry
and we'll do it with the
authority of Scripture,
but we won't do it in
the name of any movement
that runs counter to the values
that you and I
hold near and dear.
We will not do it in
any movement's name.
As a Christian, we're gonna
do it in the name of Jesus."
So again, we can separate,
but when churches begin
to drink the Kool-Aid
of social justice as interpreted
by the ideological left,
it's not just troublesome,
it's the beginning of
the slippery slope.
I would even argue the biggest
problem in America right now
is not even moral relativism
or cultural decadence,
or even big government.
The problem in America
is a lukewarm church.
It's a church and a
religious community
that's drinking the
Kool-Aid and we're bowing,
we're bowing at
the altar of race.
Somehow race just became God.
Do you realize that
there are pastors
that speak more about race
than they do about Jesus
or Moses or Abraham?
So, race and sexuality
just became idols,
and we are worshiping
on the alter of the gods
created by culture,
created by individuals
who are inclined to a morally
relativistic worldview,
who embraced anarchy and chaos,
and we're bowing to this.
And that's the
problem in America.
- So what do you
think the flaw was
in the leadership of either
the churches or the temples,
or probably in the
mosques as well,
that allowed the people that
are supposed to be the leaders
like you, the pastors,
to allow it in?
Was it the fault of the
pastors for allowing it in?
I mean, if enough people are
coming to them with something.
- It's leadership,
it always does,
it always falls on leadership.
It always falls on
leadership and we are all,
and I'm part of the collective
leadership motif here,
we're all to blame.
We are, and we need to repent.
It's a 2 Chronicles 7:14 moment.
We need to repent, we really do.
We've permitted this.
And by the way, it's this,
like, like, like,
like, like, like, like,
like, like, like, like, like.
We are more committed
to likes and followers
than we are to truth.
And when we're more committed
to likes and followers
than we are to truth, we
begin to water down truth,
acquiesce truth,
surrender truth,
and then our children
will reap the consequences
of our complacency.
Today's complacency is
tomorrow's captivity.
And right now we are complacent
and we're comfortable,
and it's a shame because
our children are watching
and they're gonna pay the price
of secular totalitarianism,
of socialism, of
communism, of anti-science.
There's no biology, human
physiology doesn't matter,
science doesn't matter.
They're gonna reap
the consequences
of our activities
in our generation.
- I can now see that my audience
will get why I
wanted to have you on
because you're hitting
so many of the topics
that I talk about all the time.
I wanna talk to you about
immigration in just a bit,
but what else did you
find in this past year
that people were coming to you?
Because I do sense what
you hinted at there
about a spiritual awakening.
I've been saying for a while,
at a micro level
I think an atheist
or an absolutely perfect secular
view of the world can work,
meaning individual
people can do that.
I think it takes a
certain type of person,
but I think it's possible.
But at the macro level,
it just simply can't work.
- It can't work, and even
the atheists and agnostics
who I have some as friends,
when we have these
conversations,
these sort of metaphysical
and cosmic conversations
of the big picture,
I call it the extension
of the Big Bang,
it's still happening,
and they even allude to
the fact, many of them,
even some of them that
are pretty prominent,
have referenced the fact
that for society to function,
we need a set of morals, mores,
a value system that has a viable
religious spiritual
component to it.
They don't negate that.
It's part of who we
are as human beings.
It's part of our spiritual
genome, without a doubt.
So yes, I have seen
in the past year,
not only just a
spiritual hunger,
but I have seen likewise
this fear of what's next,
of the immediate
sacrifice of our ability
to express ourselves spiritually
as it pertains to faith and
religion at the drop of a dime.
How we have surrendered so much
and how government is
so much more powerful
than we ever, ever would
have conceived or thought of.
That fear is there
exposing it?
- Are you shocked?
Are you shocked how quickly
everyone just kind of put
their hands up and said,
"Okay, I'm not gonna
go to church anymore,
or I'm not gonna go
to temple anymore,
or I'm not gonna go to work
anymore," et cetera, et cetera?
- I am blown away
intellectually,
emotionally, spiritually.
We just surrendered everything.
I mean, everything,
and it wasn't even,
meaning it was theoretical
back then, right?
We had no idea.
So you could argue because we
had no idea, we had the right.
I don't know if
you had the right.
I really don't.
So, here's what I
discovered, Dave,
that my constitution is
only as good and viable
as long as we don't
have an emergency.
My God-given rights come
to an end when a virus
or any other
government-deemed emergency.
- Yeah, whatever's next.
- Yeah, so they're not
absolute, they're not eternal,
because government
can take away?
Scary times.
It's revealing, it's
exposing some weaknesses
in the collective of what we
call the American experience
and the global human
experience, for that matter.
- So first off, I
normally don't ask a guest
to come back in the
middle of a show,
but I'd love to
have you come back
when we do some more
panels on religion
and I'll get you on with
some other religious leaders,
'cause I think we can
unpack a lot of that stuff.
But I wanna shift
to immigration,
'cause that's sorta how
you got on my radar.
So, there's obviously
a lot going on
at the Southern
border right now.
I'll just sorta give you
a vague question here,
which is how should
we be thinking
about what's going on here?
Because it's getting
very, very difficult
to even understand
what's remotely true,
meaning, okay, did
Obama start the cages,
and are the cages
worse because of Trump,
and then they got better,
and now it's like everything
feels like just such a mess.
- So I can give you,
not anecdotally,
but I can give you from being
involved since George W. Bush.
I worked through the Bush
administration matter
as an advisor, I worked
with Karl Rove directly,
and I worked with Obama for
eight years on this matter,
and I worked for president
Trump on this matter,
and other matters by the way.
So here it is, wow,
this is chaotic on
multiple levels.
Let me lay it out for you.
We have the ability
to solve this.
We can solve this.
The immigration crisis
is just the outcome
of political expediencies
on both sides of the aisle.
George W. Bush had
a great proposal,
it should have
passed, didn't pass.
A couple of people on
the Republican side
put a halt on that
and that's a shame.
During the Obama administration,
President Obama made
healthcare a priority,
sacrificed immigration,
and that's a shame.
And he had two years,
by the way, to do it
where he had control
of both Houses.
- Yeah, he could have
done whatever he wanted.
- He could have, boom.
So this is the fault of, again,
healthcare trumps immigration.
President Trump,
and I was there,
I was literally negotiating
between the White
House and Congress.
The president had me here
and then I would go
across the street
and speak to Speaker Pelosi.
Speaker Pelosi would tell me
to go back to the White House.
So I was negotiating
between the White House
and Congress on this.
There was a great deal.
President Trump
even surprised me
with the number of Dreamers.
He increased it times two.
he went from 800,000 to
1.6 million Dreamers.
"Pastor Sam, we're
gonna give Dreamers
a pathway to citizenship
as long as I get my wall,
and protect the border and
stop all illegal immigration."
And I went back to the speaker,
we negotiated something.
And then Chuck Schumer
came along and said,
"We're not gonna give
President Trump a win."
Do your due diligence on this.
It's been extensively covered.
So, what do we do now?
Right now on the border,
we have a crisis.
Guess what?
The cages were built
by President Obama's
administration.
There it is.
- Yeah, it's just a fact.
It's just a fact.
- The cages,
they were from the
Obama administration.
That's a matter of fact.
Even the pictures that were
used against President Trump
were from the Obama
administration.
So, that's a lie that
became, not truth,
that was perceived to
be truth by mass media.
Currently right now,
they're in the same places
that President Biden and
Kamala Harris spoke against
in every single debate.
They are actually putting
young men and women,
boys and girls, in the
same identical places.
I kid you not, the same
identical facilities
with the same
identical conditions.
- It actually seems far worse.
Aren't they more packed now?
- It is.
It's way more packed,
and I should know,
I've traveled to these
centers, I've been there.
I've interviewed,
I've interviewed custom
border patrol agents.
Many of them attend
our churches.
So, I even did some sidebars.
I went, "Hey, guys,
tell me the truth.
Just as people of faith,
please tell me the
truth off the record."
They went, "Hey, hey, Pastor
Sam, we're not setting this up
to try to convince
you of anything.
This is the reality."
So, I've been there.
The reality is right now under
the Biden administration,
there is a greater crisis
than ever during the
Trump administration
as it pertains to
children coming in.
It is tragic.
I mean, the stories
are heartbreaking.
Babies, toddlers, we're
talking about toddlers.
As a pastor and as a dad,
it's heartbreaking
to see the images.
And this is because the
Biden administration
gave a wink and a nod
for people to come over.
They did, they can't
deny it, they did,
and now we're reaping
the consequences.
But there is a solution and
here it is, here's the proposal.
Number one, we need
to secure our border.
We're a sovereign nation.
Open borders doesn't work.
Open borders invites
sex trafficking.
The drug cartels,
they are smiling.
The cartels are
smiling right now.
This idea, this notion,
is so anti-American.
And as a pastor
committed to ending
human and sex trafficking,
I repudiate what's currently
taking place at the border.
We need to secure the border.
Stop all illegal immigration.
We want people coming here
legally, not illegally,
and we can't have it both ways.
We can't permit more people
coming here illegally,
breaking the law, and
then we're telling people
that they must wear a mask.
Which is it?
- Right.
- So there's a
segment of society
that has to adhere to the law,
yet there's a group
of individuals
that don't have to adhere
to or obey the law.
That lack of continuity
subconsciously
creates a construct
which leads to behavior that
produces chaos and anarchy.
A lack of coherency, right?
So, we have to
make up our minds.
Let's protect the border,
stop illegal immigration,
and we can do it even not
just through a physical wall,
infrared technology,
satellite imaging,
come on, we could
read the license plate
from a car in Afghanistan
from a satellite.
We can stop thousands
crossing over the Rio Grande
with backpacks.
So, we have the
technology to do it.
Let's do that, let's stop
all illegal immigration.
The second thing we must
do is get the Dreamers
on a pathway to become
citizens, just the Dreamers now.
Because I still believe the kids
should not pay for the
sins of their parents.
Some of your audience
would disagree with that.
I just find it to be logical.
If you were brought over
when you were three, four, five
years old, I mean, come on,
did you vote on that? No.
- Right, and now
you're 20 years old,
and you're kicking these
people out of the country.
- Yeah, yeah, and
you grew up here,
you don't even speak Spanish.
You grew up in our
educational system.
Let's find a pathway,
as long as you're not involved
in nefarious activities,
you're not involved in
gangs, et cetera, et cetera.
Let's have these
individuals become citizens.
But their parents,
that's where I differ,
where I'm even maybe
too conservative
for some of my
friends on the right.
I don't think that the parents
who came here illegally
should ever become citizens.
- So what do you do with them?
- There's a price to pay.
We give them a green card.
So this is what we do.
If you're not living off
government entitlement,
if you're not
living off welfare,
and I know that
you're probably using
false social security
numbers, that is a crime.
You're going to have
to recognize the fact
that you broke the law, that
you have been breaking the law,
you should be paying some fines,
but you've been here for
20, 25 years working,
and some of these individuals
are some of the hardest
working individuals I know.
I live in California,
so that's just true.
I'm just speaking
truth to power.
And they attend our churches,
some of the most beautiful
people on the planet.
They should have come
here legally, by the way.
All right, did that ship sail?
Yes, but there's a price to pay.
We're gonna give
you a green card.
Stay in America.
You no longer have to
fear being deported,
but you're never gonna
become a citizen.
There's a price to pay.
How in the world can
we compensate people
that came here illegally
with citizenship,
for crying out loud,
when there are people
waiting in line
legally in nations
attempting to come into
this country the right way.
It's just wrong.
So my proposal, which I
gave to President Trump
and I gave it to a
number of senators
that are just close friends,
I said, "Here,
here's the proposal."
I call it a just
integration solution,
and I think the vast majority
of Americans would embrace this.
And matter of fact, I know,
because we did some polling
and they actually would,
including members of
the Freedom Caucus,
the most conservative
individuals who say,
"That sounds fair,
that sounds fair."
- All right, there's
a lotta different ways
we could go here.
So what do you think the wink
that you're talking about,
the Biden administration wink,
what do you think it
really is all about?
'Cause they're kinda
like, "Don't come,
maybe come in a few weeks,
you can kinda come."
But what do you think
they're actually
trying to accomplish
with the wink?
Are they trying to get
all these people there?
And do they have any
intention of actually
doing what you said, which is
we've got to secure a border
and it's the right of every
sovereign nation to do so?
- No, I don't think,
and I say this with
with due deference,
I don't think the
current administration
has any viable commitment.
I can't measure it.
If you can't measure
it, then it's not legit
as it pertains to this outcome.
I don't see any sort of evidence
that this administration
is committed
to protecting the
sovereignty of America, none.
There are many open
border operatives
that come from the
hard ideological left,
and right now, unfortunately,
they seem to have the
ear of our president.
And it is unfortunate, it is.
So I think the objective,
there's two-fold.
There are those,
and I can't judge
everyone across the board,
I'm looking at
political outcomes,
there is a group of individuals
that really with a great heart
would love to see America emerge
as the phrase on the
Statue of Liberty,
the place of refuge and hope
for people that are
broken around the world.
But that's utopia.
We can't open up for
the entire world.
We just don't have
the bandwidth.
We're not the New Jerusalem,
if you're an evangelical
or a Christian.
This is not heaven, this
is not the new earth,
whatever you wanna call it in
your theological worldview,
we're not there, so we can't.
We have to protect our borders.
The second thing is,
and this seems a little
bit more complicit,
but I know this
from conversation
with leadership
on the hard left,
there is an attempt to change
America with more voters.
And it sounds, "Oh,
that's just wild, Sam."
No, it isn't.
Again, some people are doing
it with good intentions,
yet Pollyanna-ish, a bit
of a utopic worldview.
And then there are
some that have a more
I would call it a wicked
sort of imperative,
which is let's change the
demographical landscape
to such a degree that
we're gonna secure power
for generations to come.
That's wicked because you're
dealing with human lives,
beautiful people created
in the image of God
that are seeking a better day.
We want them to do it legally.
I believe immigrants are a
blessing and not a burden
if they come here legally.
But I believe it is wicked
and morally reprehensible
to use human beings
as political pawns.
- So, did you get any sense
that Trump just could not,
or I guess this is
the sense you got,
Trump just could not
get anything done
because no matter what
he was gonna offer
that at the end, even if
Pelosi kinda nodded to it,
Schumer was gonna blow it up?
Or I don't know if we
have to blame Schumer,
but just that the machine
was just gonna say,
"We're not gonna
give the guy a win.
Sure, he's gonna double
the amount of Dreamers,
but we're not gonna give
him a win on the wall."
And this is just
how bad politics is.
- That deal was one of the
best deals that I've seen
since working on this
since 2006, it really was.
And I met with POTUS, with
President Trump on this,
and I met with General Kelly,
Secretary Nielsen back then,
and I was blown away.
I'm going like, "What
just happened? Like what?"
And his commitment, amazing,
and even when President
Trump would speak
to Hispanic Americans,
to Latino Americans,
he would repeat that,
and I'm going, whoa,
this is not part of the
collective sort of media
exacerbated narrative of a
racist president, it's not.
I mean, which is it, right?
And what he offered was a
great deal that should have,
and again, the Democrats
just said, "No,
'cause we can't give him a
win with the Latino community
and we can't give him
a win on immigration.
I mean, that just
destroys our narrative."
And it's a shame, because again,
they're playing politics
with human lives.
- So speaking of the
Latino community,
I wonder either within
your congregation
or just in your life,
there's a lot of people saying
that the Latino community
that has come here legally
and thrived for now generations,
that they're actually more
anti-illegal immigration
than the average white liberal
because they did
it the right way,
and they're sorta being bucketed
in with this whole thing.
- That's actually, that's not
like hype or a theoretical.
That's proven through
surveys time and time again,
and even recently,
in the past 48 hours,
the Latino community wants to
stop the crisis at the border
and wants to stop
illegal immigration.
Yeah, without a doubt.
The assumption that Hispanic
Americans and Latinos
are this just part
and parcel group
of a left wing
ideological worldview,
no, quite the contrary,
I can tell you firsthand,
and the numbers don't lie.
So, 36% of Latinos
supported an agenda
of what I call life,
religious liberty,
biblical justice, limited
government in the 2020 election.
And in Florida, that
was close to 50%,
which was the game
changer in Texas.
So by the way,
44% of all Latinos
voted for George
W. Bush in 2004.
So, the idea that Latinos will
probably become the future
of the conservative
movement in America,
if I were a betting
man, which I'm not, yep,
I would put some money on that.
The future conservative leaders
will probably be Latino,
because we're committed
to faith, family,
hard work, and
limited government.
So when you hear AOC and others
elevating the
notion of socialism,
Hispanics are going,
"Are you kidding?
We have cousins in Venezuela
who are literally starving.
I don't mean like fake,
I mean, literally starving
because of socialism
in Bolivia, in Nicaragua,
in Cuba with communism.
And you're telling
me that socialism
is the next for America?"
So when Latinos see
government growth,
we get anxiety attacks,
it's acid reflux.
- Well, I can tell you,
I was just in Miami
and the Cubans of
Miami, trust me,
these are the most pro-America
people you have ever...
You can't even imagine
a group of people
that would be more
pro-America, actually.
- Indeed, that's
why I do believe,
let me tell you
who's in more danger.
The ideological left
is in more danger
because of the demographical
shifts in America.
Again, all we need to do,
is if we are committed to God
over man, man over government,
to limited government, to
personal responsibility,
to our Judeo-Christian
value system
as it pertains to morality,
to nurturing family structures
that are just flourishing,
et cetera, et cetera,
if we're committed to that,
that we have to engage
the Latino community
at a different level,
and all of us must have
a greater conversation
and understand that, Dorothy,
we're not in Kansas anymore.
- How do you blend your
ability to lead a congregation,
but to also be a public figure,
to talk about politics, but
also talk about religion?
I'm sure when you're
giving a sermon,
you're trying to be as...
Well, I don't want to
put words in your mouth,
but I would imagine you're
as careful as you can be
to not be overtly political,
and yet so many people now,
because politics
is in everything,
come to you for some sort
of political leadership,
and because you've also worked
with at least three
administrations.
- Correct, I think
that the legitimacy
of working with three
administrations,
and I did not vote for all of
these presidents, I did not.
I am staunchly pro-life and
I'm not ashamed of that.
So I made a commitment
to God and to my family
that I would never vote for a
candidate that's not pro-life.
I just believe in the ethos
of life and what it means.
But with that being said,
it gives me that
sort of legitimacy.
Number two, I just wanna
speak truth with love.
So I never come out with anger,
on occasion righteous
indignation, hopefully,
but speak truth with love
and love people even
when I disagree with them
and respect them.
So, I just don't tolerate them.
It's gonna become very hippy-ish
now, California hippy-ish.
So I love people
that I disagree with.
Because I'm a Christian,
I'm called to love,
not just tolerate.
So I disagree with
you, but I respect you
and recognize that you're
created in God's image.
So I love you, even though I
disagree with you bitterly.
And that's just the sort of way
that I look at things
and approach things,
from preachings to sermons
to public platforms
on the most critical
and divisive issues.
- I think you slightly
just answered this,
but because it's
the Easter season,
because we just past Easter,
can you just talk a little
bit about how Easter,
the message of Easter,
is important right now?
- As a Christian, again, that
message to me is just powerful
and coming out of this
COVID-19 pandemic,
the fact that Jesus
came out of the tomb
enables us to come
to the reality
that with that
resurrection power,
Romans 8:11, the
apostle Paul writing,
said the same Spirit that
resurrected Jesus lives in you,
we can come out of despair.
We can come out of anxiety,
fear, confusion, chaos.
We can come out of brokenness.
We can come out of the
most dire of circumstances.
Jesus came out of the tomb.
You and I can come out
of the most precarious,
negative of
circumstances by faith.
That's the resurrection message,
that there is eternal life
through the vicarious,
atoning work of Christ
and there's life even
beyond this life.
But when we're on
this side of eternity,
we can be light and
live out that life
where I just don't ask
God for a blessing,
I ask God to make me a blessing,
where I ask God to
make me the answer
to someone else's prayer.
I really believe that through
that resurrection message,
we can change the world.
- Do you ever have
doubts anymore?
- Yeah, absolutely, and to say
I don't would lack integrity.
Yes, and this is
gonna sound awkward,
I embrace them because it
reminds me of my humanity
and it prompts me to have a
continual conversation with God,
with my thoughts to prove,
to test my ideology,
my belief system.
I think it's beautiful.
And I don't think God is ever
afraid of our questions, ever.
I think we have a God who
welcomes queries and questions.
I love it, I love it, I love it.
I just absolutely love it.
Hey, Adam and Eve,
Genesis, God turns around
and says after the fall,
"Hey, Adam, where are you?"
Like he didn't know, right?
(Dave chuckling)
It's just a question
of find yourself.
Do you know where
you really are,
really, in life, with me,
with purpose, where are you?
So I love questions.
Doubts don't bother me.
I welcome them, as long as they
don't put a lid on my faith.
- I'm curious, did
you track the rise
of Jordan Peterson at all?
Were you paying-
- Full disclosure, I'm a fan.
- Oh, okay, all right, well,
then that's a perfect segue,
because as you bring
up Adam and Eve,
and we can talk obviously
about biblical stories,
he did so much on
these biblical stories.
And what I saw that
was so fascinating
when I was on tour with him
was that people who
were not religious,
they were either
atheist or agnostic
or just sort of a-religious
or hadn't really
thought about it much,
suddenly they're hearing
him talk about these stories
that they kinda
know through culture
or maybe some religious
teaching or something,
and it was changing them,
and it was just incredible for
me to see night after night.
- No, these narratives of
Scripture are full of truth
and virtue and life lessons
that are eternal, eternal.
To this very moment,
this very hour,
if we pass these teachings down
from one generation
to the other, there's
hope for the next.
- Indeed.
What else is on
your mind right now,
not only as a preacher,
but as a leader,
as someone involved in
the political world?
And what else are you
thinking about right now?
- I am concerned.
I actually spoke to
my wife about this
before we came together
for this interview.
Last night, I said, "Honey,
I need to be careful
of I find myself on the fence
dipping a little bit on,
not drinking the
Kool-Aid of despair,
but things are just going
to hell in a handbasket
legislatively as it
pertains to values
and rights that we have.
I'm concerned about
the next generation."
I don't wanna go into a pit,
so what's in my mind is,
instead of focusing
on the darkness,
turning on the light,
and how do we do that?
Let's mobilize people,
let's message and mobilize
for the purpose of not
drinking the Kool-Aid
and tolerating this reality
as if we could do absolutely
nothing to build a firewall.
I wanna build a firewall of
righteousness and justice.
I have this crazy worldview
that we can do this.
We can push back.
Moral relativism,
cultural decadence,
big government telling
me there is no such thing
as gender and truth and
science and faith and God,
we can push back against
anarchy and chaos.
That's what's on my mind,
a multi-generational,
multiethnic movement of
righteousness and justice,
truth and love,
that's what's on mine.
- Well, with that in mind,
do you think we can recall
this Gavin Newsom guy or what?
- I sure hope so.
I sure hope so.
We need to flip California
because it's just crazy.
This is secular totalitarianism.
It's crazy, it's nutty.
- Are you shocked?
Are you shocked that so many...
I mean, the thing that always
gets me with Californians,
especially I'm in LA,
it's like they always
know something's wrong.
If you ask someone,
"How's it going in LA?"
everyone's like, "Oh, there's
homeless people everywhere.
The drugs, the taxes are high."
And then you're like, "All
right, well, you do realize
we're just voting for one
party endlessly forever."
And they can't seem
to put that together.
- Yeah, and by the way, that's
Pete Wilson, God bless him,
he did that, I kid you not.
California, listen folks, Dave
knows this, Sam knows this,
California, you gotta engage
the Latino vote, you have to.
It's the demographical
reality, right,
and way before, and
this is not just now,
that's just California.
So, when he came along
and just alienated,
flipped off the
Latino vote, boom,
that was the beginning of
a downhill slide in cycle
that he gave California
to one party,
and it's dangerous,
one-party rule.
However, the level of
frustration right now and angst,
it's up here.
So we have moderate Democrats
and what I call
thinking Democrats
that don't drink the
ideological Kool-Aid,
but are centrist and more
moderate, more common sense.
The JFK, that remnant that's
still around, minority,
but still around, that John
F. Kennedy sort of Democrat,
they're waking up and
going, like, "What is this?"
So I think California
could actually change.
It's doable.
It just requires a lot
of different coalitions,
very unique coalitions.
- You've given me
a lotta hope here,
but I feel I should give you
one last moment of
hope to go out on.
- It's real simple.
At the end of the day,
at the end of the day,
love overcomes hate,
truth defeats the lie.
It may take a cycle or two,
but at the end of the day,
I still believe that
every single time
light stands next to
darkness, light always wins.
So regardless of
whatever emerges,
using the Old Testament
as a context here,
Pharaoh, Goliath,
Nebuchadnezzar, Jezebel,
God, for whatever reason,
always appointed men and women
to rise up and push back.
So for every Pharaoh,
there must be a Moses.
And for every Goliath,
there must be a David.
For every Jezebel,
there must be an Elijah,
for every Nebuchadnezzar,
there must be a Daniel.
And in the New Testament,
for every Herod,
there must be a Jesus.
Let not your heart be troubled.
There's always gonna be light,
and light will always
overcome darkness.
- All right, well, on that note,
I'm trying to do more
of these types of shows
to give people some
things that aren't just
in that horizontal
world that we have,
but also in that
vertical world we have.
So, I hope you'll come back.
And one of these days, we'll
meet somewhere in So Cal
when they let us
out of our houses.
- (laughing) Will do.
Honored to be with you.
Thank you for having me.
- Sam, it was a pleasure,
thank you so much.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about spirituality
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our
spirituality playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.